on problem 148 what is the lowest
integer that it is a sum of three
different primes each greater than 20 so
it's the lowest integer so is we
essentially just have to find the three
Prime's above 20 so let's see 21 isn't
deprived 22 is into prime 23 is a prime
24 no 25 no 26 no 27 28 nope 29 that's
prime 30 isn't 31 is so what's this 31
plus 29 is 60 plus 23 is 83 and that is
choice E I hope I haven't missed any
Prime's no I don't think I have 24 25 26
27 28 nope I think that's I got all the
primes in there what is the lowest
energy to sum of three different Prime's
each greater than 20 yep that's the
answer
e problem 149 the average of 6 8 and 10
equals so the average of 6 8 and 10 so
first of all what's the average of 6 8
and 10 6 well let's just do it 6 plus 8
plus 10 but you should you could
immediately see that the average is
going to be 8 right because you have 8
in the middle and both of these numbers
are 2 away from it but that divided by 3
is equal to 24 divided by 3 is equal to
8 right 24 divided by 3 and that's equal
to the average of 7 plus 9 plus x over 3
so that tells us multiply both sides of
this equation by 3 that says that 24 is
equal to what's 7 plus 9 that's 16 plus
X subtract 16 from both sides you get X
is equal to 8 choice C and you could
have said okay well 7 and 9 are both
half eights in the middle and they have
to average 8 so you might have just been
able to eyeball and say oh 8 but didn't
take that much math so it's not that
much of a shortcut problem 150 if X is
equal to minus 1 X is equal to minus 1
then X to the 4th minus X to the 3rd
plus x squared all of that over X minus
1 is equal to what
so X to the fourth is 1 X to the third
is minus 1 right but then we're going to
minus that so this whole thing is going
to be plus 1 and x squared is plus 1
right 1 negative 1 squared is 1 1 and
you have minus 1 minus 1 so in the
numerator you have 1 2 3 the denominator
you have minus 2 let's put the minus out
front minus 3 halves and that's choice a
problem 151 a toy store regularly sells
all stock at a discount of 20 to 40% so
20 to 40% if an additional 25% were
deducted from the discount price during
a special sale what would be the lowest
possible price of a toy costing 16
dollars before any discount so we want
to discount this 16 dollars as much as
possible right so they say that you
you're normally discounting 20 to 40% so
if we want to discount this as much as
possible we want to discount this by 40%
so if you discount this by 40% that's
the same thing as saying it's going to
be equal to 60 percent of its original
price so this would be the price after
being discounted by 40 percent right and
then and then we would discount by
another 25 percent right actually I
think it's easier to go the other way
well well let's just do it this way so
we discount by another 25% so we'd
multiply it by three-fourths again right
if you discount by 25% the prices going
to be 3/4 of its original price so let's
do it as fractions fractions are always
easier so 60 percent of your price
that's 3/5 right if you discount by 2/5
or 40 percent that's the same thing as
multiplying by 3/5 and then we're going
to multiply by 3/4 right set 25 percent
if you're discounting by 25 percent
that's the same thing as being worth 75
percent of your original price so what
does that get us let's see we can do
some 16 divided by 4 get a 4 get 1
and then you have 4 times 3 times 3 4
times 3 times 3 is 4 times 9 is 36 over
5 which is equal to what's that 5 goes
into 36 7 . 7 and 1/5 so 7 dollars and
20 cents and that's choice B problem 152
the shaded portion of the rectangular
lot shown above represents the flowerbed
okay so let me draw this rectangular lot
draw this rectangular lot they drew this
shaded portion something like that and I
could even color it in colored it in so
they say the shaded portion of the
rectangular lot shown above represents a
flowerbed if the area of the bed is 24
square yards 24 square yards and X is
equal to y plus 2 so they tell us that
this side right here is X which now
they're telling us is equal to y plus 2
and this is right here it's going to be
equal to Y this right here is y and they
say then Z equals what Z is this side
right there so if this area is 24 that
tells us that x times y times 1/2 is 24
right that's the area of that so 1/2 X Y
is equal to 24 or you could even say
that XY is equal to 48
and we know what XY is we can just
substitute for X so we get Y plus 2
that's X right X is equal to y plus 2
times y is equal to 48 and so we get Y
squared plus 2y is equal to 48 or Y
squared plus 2y minus 48 is equal to 0
so we could factor this quadratic this
is
see what two numbers when you multiply
minus 48 and you add you get plus 2c y
plus 8 times y minus 6 is equal to 0
right 8 times minus 6 is minus 48 and
then 8 minus 6 is plus 2 so Y could be
equal to minus 8 or plus 6 right
whatever numbers make either of these
equal to 0 well we can't have a negative
distance so Y is not equal to minus 8 so
Y is equal to 6 y is equal to 6 X is
equal to 8 all right and we can just
confirm 6 times 8 is 48 times 1/2 is
equal to 24 and now we can use
Pythagorean theorem to figure out Z so
we'll get Z squared is equal to 36
that's y squared plus 64 which is x
squared so Z squared is equal to 100 Z
is equal to 10 choice e problem 153 153
Jack is now 14 years older than Bill so
jack is equal to bill plus 14 if in 10
years Jack will be twice as old as Bill
so Jack in 10 years is going to be twice
as old as Bill so 2 times bills age how
old will Jack be in 5 years so they want
to know J plus 5 right that's how old
Jack will be in five years so let's just
try to solve for Jack so let's see if we
with this top equation tells us that
tells us that bill is equal to Jack
minus 14 and then we can substitute this
in for Bill here so then this equation
will become Jack plus 10 is equal to 2
times Jack minus 14 so Jack plus 10 is
equal to 2 times Jack - 28 let's see if
we subtract Jack from both sides we get
10 is equal to Jack - 28 we can add 28
to both sides and you
at 38 is equal to Jack so that's how
well Jack is now he's 38 years old so
how old is Jack going to be in five
years 38 plus 5 is equal to 43 years old
and I've clearly made a mistake because
it's that's not one of the options so
let's see where I made an error so Jack
is now 14 years older than Bill fair
enough if in 10 years so in 10 years
Jack will be twice as oh I see my
mistake he's going to be twice as old as
Bill is going to be in 10 years
that was a boneheaded mistake so let me
clear all of this that was a bad mistake
he shouldn't have made it should not
have made it I'm lucky that they didn't
that they didn't have what I put down is
one of the choices and I would have
gotten it wrong all right so we know
that in 10 years jack is going to be 2
times what Bill is going to be in 10
years that was my mistake so now let's
see what we could do now let's try to
say well we'll use that same information
up there so bill is equal to Jack minus
14 substitute that information here so
we get Jack plus 10 is equal to 2 times
Jack minus 14 instead of Bill plus 10 so
you get Jack plus 10 is equal to 2 times
Jack let's see minus 14 plus 10 that's
minus 4 so Jack plus 10 is equal to 2
times Jack minus 8 let's subtract Jack
from both sides 10 is equal to Jack
minus 8 let's add 8 to both sides you
get 18 is equal to Jack so that's how
old Jack is right now he's 18 so in five
years jack is going to be 18 plus 5
since 23 years old
choice D and I'm out of time see in the
next video